movie transfer vulnerability exploited
by hackers number second unpest IBM as
period for spec file transfer service
under active attack third exploit
released for go anywhere file transfer
zero day flow every year millions of
dollars are lost and thousands of
Enterprises and individuals are impacted
due to vulnerabilities in file sharing
systems more specifically speaking
Network file sharing systems with large
volume and velocity of data is
continuously moved and stored hundreds
of times every second between thousands
of connected nodes servers and computers
hello everyone and welcome back to
Simply learn YouTube channel in today's
video we'll discuss what are network
file sharing system exploits how they
work and how to prevent them it is very
important for cyber security Enthusiast
professionals and students to be aware
of network file sharing systems as it
forms the backbone of every Enterprise
and organizations across the globe and
before we begin if you are someone who
is interested in building a career in
cyber security by graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with cyber
security by learning from the export
then try giving a short to Simply lens
postgraduate program in cyber security
with modules from MIT Schwartzman
College of Engineering the course link
is mentioned in the description box
below if these are the types of videos
you would like to watch then hit the
Subscribe button like and press on the
Bell icon to not miss on further content
so stay tuned with us until the end of
this video and don't forget to register
your opinion in the comment section
below and here we start with what is
Network file sharing
so Network file sharing is a process by
which two or more computers on a network
can access share and collaborate on
files that are stored on a central
location
such as a server or a shared folder it
typically involves a combination of
network protocols access controls and
authentication mechanisms by using
network file sharing users can work
together on projects or store and
retrieve data from a central location
without having to physically copy or
transfer files from one device to
another
this can improve productivity and reduce
cost by reducing the need for physical
storage devices such as flash drives or
external hard drives now we'll see the
types of network file sharing
so there are two main types of network
file sharing that is direct file sharing
and distribute file sharing so first
we'll see direct file sharing so it's a
method of sharing files between two or
more computers over a network without
the use of a dedicated server or storage
device files are typically shared over a
local area network that is Lan or wide
area network Wan using protocols such as
file transfer protocol FTP simple file
transfer protocol SFTP for the common
internet file system cifs and the next
type of network file sharing is that is
distributed file sharing so it involves
a central storage device such as a
server or a network attached storage
device that multiple clients can access
over a network the clients can access
and modify the files stored on the
server and the changes are automatically
saved to the server distributed file
sharing is a popular method of sharing
files in Enterprise environments as it
allows multiple users to access and use
the same file simultaneously without the
need for manual sharing or coping code
files between devices examples of
distributed file sharing systems include
Microsoft file server novel Network and
Sun Microsystems Network file system NFS
and we have another type of network file
sharing that is content delivery Network
CDN so cdns are a type of distributed
Network that consists of servers located
around the world that cache and deliver
web content to users with high speed and
low latency cdns are often used to
improve the performance and scalable
delivery of web applications as well as
to reduce server load and bandwidth cost
they work by caching and delivering
content from Edge locations that are
closer to users reducing the need for
users to access content from original
source and reducing the distance the
content needs to travel over the
internet as a result cdns can provide
high speed delivery of content to users
and reduce the server load of the origin
server reducing bandwidth cost and it's
a powerful method for delivering web
content images and videos and is used by
many companies to distribute their
software updates media content and
applications and now moving on we will
see what is Network file sharing exploit
so it refers to vulnerable abilities
that allow attackers to gain
unauthorized access to files or services
on a network these attacks can be
particularly dangerous because they
often involve taking control of
sensitive resources such as user
accounts financial information or
intellectual property and to better
understand Network file sharing exploits
it's important to have a basic
understanding of computer security so
here are some key Concepts to know
first we'll start with the key Concepts
and the first key concept is operating
system so an operating system is a
software program that manages resources
on a computer it is responsible for
controlling Hardware components such as
the CPU memory and storage and
coordinating the execution of software
applications and the next is Network
protocols so Network Protocols are sets
of rules that communication between
computers on a network some examples of
network protocols include HTTP which
Powers the web SMB server message block
and NFS Network file system then we have
another key concept that is
authentication authentication is the
process of verifying the identity of a
user or system before granting access to
resources this can be done using methods
such as passwords tokens or biometric
Authentication the next concept is
authorization authorization is the
process of determining whether a user or
system has the necessary permissions to
access a resource this can be done using
access control such as user roles
permissions or access policies the next
we have is exploitation exploitation is
the act of taking advantage of a
vulnerability in software or a system to
gain unauthorized access or control this
can involve techniques such as buffer or
close Crow side scripting and malware
Network file sharing exploits take
advantage of vulnerabilities in the
network protocols or authentication
mechanisms used by computers to share
files or resource on a network for
example an indecker May exploit a
vulnerability in the SMB protocol to
gain access to a remote file share so at
a high level Network file sharing
exploits can be broken down into several
stages and now we'll see that stages how
these hackers break into the file
sharing and do exploit it so the first
is
penetration testing before attackers can
exploit the vulnerabilities they must
first identify them so this may involve
techniques such as Port scanning
vulnerability assessment and social
engineering the next is exploitation
once the attacker has identified the
vulnerabilities they can attempt to
exploit them to gain access to the
network or a specific resource this may
involve using specialized attack tools
or writing a custom exploit for a
specific vulnerability and the next is
escalation once the attacker has gained
access to a network or a resource they
may need to escalate their privileges to
access more sensitive information or to
execute more advanced attacks this may
involve methods such as privilege
escalation credential theft or lateral
movement next we have is privilege
escalation if the attacker can gain
access to an administrative account or a
service account with high privileges
they can potentially execute more
advanced attacks this may involve
modifying system settings creating new
user account or installing malware the
next concept is data exfiltration so
this is a stage note the concept once
the attacker has gained control of
sensitive data they may attempt to
exfiltrate it either by uploading it to
a remote server or by stealing it using
removable media
and the next thing they do is clean up
after the attack the attacker may try to
cover their tracks by deleting logs
disabling monitoring tools or modifying
system settings this is often done to
make it more difficult or administrators
to identify and investigate the incident
so to protect against Network file
sharing exploits it is important to
implement through security measures such
as regular patching strong access
controls and effective logging and
monitoring it is also important to train
employees to be aware of potential
threats to report suspicious activity
and to follow established security
protocols and now we'll see some
examples of network file sharing
exploits
the first is SMB server message block so
it's a file sharing protocol used by
Windows operating system it has been the
target of several high profile
vulnerabilities including Eternal blue
and blue cable so these are the attacks
that have been done attackers can use
these vulnerabilities to execute
arbitrary code on a remote computer
potentially leading to account takeover
data theft or other malicious activities
the next is FTB file transfer protocol
it's another file sharing protocol
commonly used on the internet it is
often used to transfer files between
servers and clients however it is also
prone to several vulnerabilities
including the ability to execute remote
commands modify files or steal sensitive
information the next is NFS Network file
system it's a file sharing protocol used
primarily on Unix based systems like SMB
and FTP NFS has also been the target of
several high profile vulnerabilities
including a vulnerability that allowed
attackers to execute arbitrary code on
remote system
the next we have is RC that stands for
remote code execution
which refers to a type of vulnerability
that allows attackers to execute
arbitrary code on a remote system it is
often associated with network file
sharing that exploits and can lead to
Serious consequences including account
takeover data theft or other malicious
activities
now we'll see some reasons why Network
file sharing exploits occur so the first
is weak authentication mechanisms weak
authentication mechanisms in network
file sharing protocols can be exploited
by attackers to gain unauthorized access
to sensitive files common
vulnerabilities include default or
easily guessable passwords unencrypted
authentication credentials and Brute
Force attacks implementing strong
authentication mechanisms such as
two-factor authentication and enforcing
password complexity is crucial to
prevent unauthorized access now we will
see the vulnerability too that is
misconfigured permissions
so misconfigured permissions on shared
files and directories can lead to
unintended access and data leakage
attackers can exploit this vulnerability
and gain access to confidential
information or modify critical files it
is important to regularly review and
update permissions ensuring that only
authorized users have appropriate access
rights additionally implementing Access
Control list can provide granular
control over file permissions now we'll
see the vulnerability 3 that is lack of
encryption so Network file sharing
protocols that transmit data in plain
text expose sensitive information to
eavesdropping and interception attackers
can capture Network traffic and extract
confidential data without detection
implementing encryption such as
transport layer security TLS or secure
shell SSH ensures that data is encrypted
during transmission preventing
unauthorized access and data tampering
now we'll see the vulnerability for that
is malware distribution NATO file
sharing can serve as a vector for
malware distribution attackers can
upload infected files to share
directories spreading malware across the
network users who download these files
unknowingly introduce malware into their
systems regularly scanning shared files
for malware using up-to-date antivirus
software and educating users about save
file sharing practices are essential to
prevent malware infections so now we'll
see some examples of popular Network
file sharing exploits that have occurred
over the years the first is eternal blue
Eternal blue was a high profile
vulnerability in Microsoft server
message block SMB file sharing protocol
that allowed attackers to take control
of vulnerable systems remotely it has
been used to launch several high profile
cyber attacks including the Wanna Cry
ransomware attack in 2017.
and the next is blue keep another SME
vulnerability blue Cape that is affected
Windows operating system and allowed
attackers to gain control of vulnerable
systems remotely it was discovered in
2019 and could potentially affect
millions of system the next we have is
Samba cry another SMB vulnerability
Samba cry that allowed attackers to take
control of unpatched system turning the
open source Samba file Samba file you
can say Samba or semi it's up to you so
it was discovered in 2019 and could
potentially affect millions of systems
that rely on Samba and the next we have
is hurt bleed so herd bleed was a
serious vulnerability in the open SSL
cryptographic software library that
allowed attackers to steal sensitive
information from victim systems it
affected millions of websites and
applications and was widely exploited
when it was initially discovered in 2014
and the next we have is shell shock so
shell shock was a serious onlineability
in The Bash cell that allowed attackers
to execute arbitrary commands on well
enabled system it affected systems
running Linux and unique space operating
system and could potentially affect
millions of systems it was discovered in
2014 and was widely exploited
so this was the attacks or these was the
attacks that Network file sharing
experts and that happened and these were
the popular ones
and in conclusion what I have to say is
that Network file sharing is a
convenient way to share files and
collaborate but it also introduced
vulnerabilities that can be experted by
attackers so to protect sensitive data
and maintain the Integrity of the
network it is crucial to implement
strong authentication mechanisms
regularly review and update permissions
encrypt Network traffic and educate
users about save file sharing practices
by addressing these vulnerabilities
organizations can mitigate the risk
associated with network file sharing and
this was all for this tutorial and now
let's take a minute to hear from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers hi I'm Philip
I'm 61 years old and last year IOP scale
with simple Learners post program and
cyber security after working 30 years in
the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course course I
must say was with practical examples it
was led by highly skilled certified
instructors I worked with many companies
before the security analysts and the
architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with Infosys as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here